for those people who are just out of
college that
it's okay to not know instead of trying
to have a clear path and destination to
where you want to be as a
mid to late career think about what you
value
[Music]
david weekley thank you so much for
being on my show it's been seven years
since we last seen each other but
i am so excited to reclaim all that
inspiration that i had back then thank
you for joining me
please to be here thank you i i can't
even imagine how busy your schedule is
given everything that you do
and first i want to start by thanking
you for coming seven years ago to one of
the hackathons that i organized back in
redwood city
hacking generation i gave such a
wonderful keynote and that
i keep visiting and people's been
talking about it ever since then so
really thank you for
for talking and it was about doing it
was about exploring and having passion
and having curiosity
and i'm excited to having to let that
shine through here i'm gonna do a
really brief intro about you even though
it's not gonna do justice
but just bear with me because i have to
get the context of who you are
founded pb works then managing founder
of
mexico mexican dot vc and i believe you
returned 11
x on the cash on cash the most uh
profitable at mexican vc and in history
i believe
entrepreneur residents trinity ventures
founded gaston labs
product manager at facebook after the
acquisition of another startup of yours
oh
ohana a head of product of various
things at google
and most recently the founder and ceo of
medporter
which i want to spend a chunk of time
talking about because i'm just so
excited about your mission
hacker dojo which i didn't even mention
way too much to talk about david
who are you how do you get to do so many
things
what is this um so i'm i'm a nerd who
loves people
and i think a lot of what i build just
comes out of that i like to build things
i like to learn new technical systems
i'm a product guy so i like building
solutions to problems and conspiring
with other people to go and build those
things and then finally i just i like
bringing people together i like
connecting people i get a lot of
personal satisfaction
out of doing that and so uh if if you
look at the
mishmash of of stuff that i've done
it it probably doesn't seem like it is
constructed in a coherent narrative arc
right and that's because it it wasn't
candidly you know i think a lot of
people
starting their careers try to ask the
question like
where do i want to be in 5 10 20 years
like what is my career going to look
like
and it's a tremendously intimidating
question right because you look at
people who are very very successful
and i think a lot of people conclude
these people must have
just upon graduating college sat down
thought really hard and come up with
this beautiful story arc of where their
life was going to go
and how they were going to get there um
and oh my gosh
i don't have that written down and and
or i do and it's not
credible right and and what am i going
to do i must be a failure because that
is the path to success having this clear
multi-decade narrative arc of what your
career is going to be
and if you actually get to know a number
of very famous and successful people
um generally it doesn't work like that
right that they're
they're they're likely hard-working
they're likely intelligent
they're likely uh charismatic or figured
out how to be um that's actually
something you can learn to be
um and and then a number of lucky
opportunities
came came about and they were able to
take advantage of those because they
were
clever and hard-working and
well-connected and liked people right
and could motivate people to go and work
on
work on missions right and so life often
is is much more
random that then we want to give it an
account for so i would say
for those people who are just out of
college that uh
it's okay to not know instead of trying
to have a clear path and destination to
where you want to be as a
mid to late career think about what you
value
right if you enjoy learning great you
should make sure that
any job that you take you're going to be
learning something
if you enjoy having broad impact and
looking at numbers and metrics
great you don't need to be embarrassed
about that go go run with that
if you enjoy building something brand
new
then great you don't need to be
embarrassed about that
one other thing that often comes up in
people's career trajectories
is that they find themselves embarrassed
about things that are off that narrative
arc
maybe you really like being a scuba
diver or you like horses
or you like spending time uh learning
how to go and do ballroom dancing
right and these things don't feel like
they're working toward
a successful career end point right
they're outside of this narrative art
what do i do
and what's funny is oftentimes these
things that
make you weird your unique particular
collection of interests and experiences
that nobody else has
ends up making you valuable right
um so what what what we want
increasingly is people who are
non-fungible who can't just be swapped
out like cogs of a wheel
but whose weird experiences
give them unique insights and ways of
tackling the problems in front of them
that only they could have had because
only
they are coming at the problem with
those set
of of weird backgrounds and experiences
so i think
going back to my own uh trajectory in
arc a lot of it was like that
it was trying to optimize for learning
trying to optimize for
impact um trying to not be in a rut or
get bored or not developing myself
further
always hungry to see what problems can i
solve that that need to be solved out
there in the world
um and and how can i do that in in an
enjoyable way
right and and so i thought across a lot
of people when you
when you optimize how do you optimize
for learning in a world that is such a
it's one you know convoluted race
towards the top
towards the greatest funding towards the
greatest start the greatest success you
know
i'm walking the streets of palo alto i'm
studying with
with incredible people i've served in
the israel military with some incredible
people
and it doesn't feel that always
optimized for learning is is
is something that one can afford right
because we have to move so quickly
how do you optimize for learning how can
you possibly succeed if you're not
continuously learning
right is that the end endpoint is not
defined the pie
is not fixed this is not a a
race where where the rules are are
prescribed
and it's clear how to succeed it's
obvious how to build a billion dollar
company
and and you you just need to sit down
and do the work
right real life isn't like that the the
new billion dollar
opportunities by definition haven't been
sussed out haven't been fleshed out
they're going to require thinking about
things in a new way and doing
things in a new way you want to be
cognizant of
approaches and methodologies that are
generally shown to be successful
or not successful you want to learn from
you know your own failures as well as
the failures of those around you in
terms of
what structurally works or not i'm not
saying ignore everything
but i am saying that that that process
of continually learning is a critical
one for
modern employment like so you take a
look at uh technical product management
right so anyone who's a pm at google and
pretty much anyone's a pm at
facebook and they need to not only have
their fingers on
on the pulse of what are real unsolved
problems that are out there in the real
world
but then on the other hand they're
trying to match those to what is the
state of the art and technology
right grab off the shelf and what
can i not yet grab off the shelf but i
have enough technical depth to know is
possible and attainable and it's not
just magic sprinkle fairy dust right
um and you've got enough credibility to
go and map that out to say
i'm going to take these four pieces
three of which have been known and well
defined for decades
two of which only became possible in the
last couple months
and then there's this one extra part
over here that doesn't yet exist
but i'm confident that with this team of
engineers i can be able to invent on it
and
here's the reason why i think it's it's
tractable
and de-riskable from technical
perspective i'm gonna put these things
together and i'm gonna solve this big
problem over here
that is otherwise unsolved right and i'm
gonna be the first person to go and have
this new way of looking at the problem
this new solution for this problem
and if you are not keeping up on not
only
what was commercially viable because it
was out there but also
as academia advances in understanding
what soon will be possible
and what commercial impacts that is
going to have if you're not
looking into the crystal ball there
you're going to miss out on
opportunities
things that were impossible five years
ago
uh you'll you'll miss as possible
solutions because they're possible that
one weren't then
and so you won't think to build the
product in that way leveraging those
technologies right so you'll miss out
so there's there's a lot of different
ways in which uh
in almost any part of the stack whether
you're a designer
or a marketer or an engineer or a
product manager
or a ceo almost any role in the company
you can think of
even if you're doing qa testing the
state of the art is continuing to evolve
pretty quickly
and what that does is it gives super
powers to
the people who are able to keep up with
it you can see
in this era small teams have
ridiculously sized impact of far more
than they've been able to
at pretty much any other point in human
history a team of
a dozen or so people can build a product
that a billion people use right that's
never unbelievable it's unbelievable and
so you think about
what do those couple dozen people need
to know
they all need to know how to operate at
scale they need to be able to harness
the
the tools the methodologies the
frameworks that are out there
to operate and scale and and to be
effective right and then
to keep up with that now i i want to
nuance that a little bit with there's so
much that's new
always coming out that trying to be
completely on top of
absolutely every new development in
every field is just not possible for any
human being
particularly if you're also say trying
to build a company at the same time
right so you'll have to acknowledge that
even when you're trying to optimize for
learning and keep up on things
you're gonna miss a lot um a that's okay
no need to beat yourself up there really
are only 24 hours in the day for
absolutely everybody
and b you can also figure out how to
leverage your your networks to help you
proxy for other areas
so um if you're focused in some area
over here
then as long as you know who to talk to
about some of these
other areas so they can sort of keep
their ear to the ground for you
um then then you can have sort of
disproportionate impact there because
you know i don't need to keep up on the
state of the art and say uh biotech
that's way outside of stuff i know a lot
about
and it's okay for me to not know a lot
about that but i can have interesting
conversations with friends of mine
who are deep in that and so i can go and
ping them when i have questions there
so you don't have to do it all yourself
either i think i think that's just
fascinating david if i look at
your judgment the different things that
you've done the incredible things you've
done
it's a really remarkable balance between
continuing your
your own journey as an entrepreneur as
an investor as a thinker but also giving
back to the community
so many of your projects are involving
the community helping
others get started helping others pursue
their passions what is that about
why where does all this motivation and
passion
for the community building come along
with your trajectory of of being a great
engineer great entrepreneur
i think the short answer is because it's
fun it's fun to throw
parties it's fun to introduce people to
each other that end up hitting it off
and
investing in each other working together
to found a company
it's fun to meet with founders who are
filled with passion for going and
bringing new products into the world
and conspiring with them around ways to
help their dreams come true
it's an enjoyable thing to do so even
just from a purely selfish perspective
um
i i help the community because i enjoy
doing that
i think some of it also is a critical
cultural component of silicon valley i
think there's silicon valley's not a
perfect place there's a lot of things to
hate about it
um and you know there's certainly been
lots of discourse
around people leaving san francisco in
particular which is one part of the bay
area
um that i think is is valid and pointed
but i think there are some aspects of
silicon valley culture
that are really positive and are also
stealable right so you can incorporate
these aspects into
other cultures and other geographies as
well and and i think one of the ones
that i love
is an overall pay it forward mentality
you know i think most other business
ecosystems operate on a very mercenary
kind of a basis so you only take a
meeting with somebody
if it's clear what they're going to be
able to do for you
and and what you're going to be able to
do for them right so there's sort of a
tit for tat it's a matching appears
um and it means that it can be very
difficult to meet with
people who are powerful people who are
wealthy right
um and it's frankly it's a little bit
more of a fixed pie mentality right so
um the rich help the rich the folks who
are early trying to help folks who are
early but it's always
in exchange for something and that sort
of market making
where you're trying to match up very
evenly
to people who can get the equal amount
of value for each other
just the math says there's going to be
fewer of those pairings
right but if you if you come at an
ecosystem with a pay it forward
mentality
there's an enormous explosion in the
number of positive
connections that can happen uh and what
what what capitalism will tell you is
that any
any time there's there's an exchange
value is created
right and so by encouraging there to be
more of those exchanges
by not looking at the mercenary equal
value exchange tip for tat you end up
growing the value of the ecosystem much
more dramatically
and we actually you mentioned you're in
tel aviv right now we actually saw this
happen
in the israeli startup ecosystem
starting with the icq acquisition
because after icq the founders turned
around and not only
invested their capital but also their
know-how in helping build up the israeli
startup ecosystem
and that really i would say just as an
outside observer
is where i really stop saw things start
to explode and so the fact that
israel could apply this silicon valley
style mentality of
reinvest your time and your money and
ecosystem
we really saw things blow up so out here
on in silicon valley you take a look at
the most experienced
venture capital firms that are providing
the most disproportionate return
what's true of the vcs there generally
they're disproportionately former
operators themselves right
because they love helping entrepreneurs
they can give actionable
advice and guidance on what to do at
difficult parts in the startups journey
and they've been there before which
gives them credibility with founders for
highly competitive deals
right you look at the investment
ecosystem in most other
parts of the planet the people making
the decisions about whether or not to
back an early stage company
have never done it themselves and they
actually look
down on it right you know when they
themselves
in a number of different ecosystems
inherited that money from their father's
corruption right and so
like they're very big on themselves and
they're very down
on the on the lowly entrepreneurs who
have to you know come crawling on their
knees like
please give me your money esteemed
investor right
and right really none of that kind of
mentality or structure
it's it's not present to nearly the same
extent i would say here
in silicon valley where it's sort of
expected that
you're going to try your best to go and
build something if it's successful
you're going to pay it back you know
whether that's because you're going to
be a vc and help other companies succeed
or you're going to
advise and mentor others or
maybe there's going to tool in your
garage and build awesome open source
that everyone can use but
whatever it is that um you're going to
go
and pay it back into the ecosystem and a
lot of the buildings
that are the the billionaires that are
here
became billionaires disproportionately
because other people
went in and helped them with again no
expectation
around uh around return right
these were people who helped just
because it was fun to help people who
were starting things who were founding
things
and great things come out of that so
like pinterest was actually started at
hackerdojo right
um yeah yeah what
yeah lambda school as well started at
hackerdojo so
okay so two give me two words about
hacker dojo just for anybody who doesn't
know
yeah so unfortunately the facility is
closed right now during coronavirus but
uh what it is it's a non-profit
community center
for people to go and improve their
technical skills so this is
helping people who are just getting into
tech for the first time
as well as helping people who already
maybe have mastered some areas of
technology to come
and level up even more right so you
could start sort of think of it like
halfway between an incubator and like an
anarchist community college
uh i love it i love it yeah so it's just
it's it
it's run on a membership basis but we we
when we're open we have 10 times more
people than members come through the
front doors
to go and take classes in machine
learning um
in android programming and whatever else
it is we've got all kinds of meetups
we've got a small
uh machine shop there so you can go and
build some physical things
solder components etc yeah i love it i
mean
the chairman of hacker dojo but david
med quarter i i i see a lot of
early stage startups right now uh very
lucky to be part of a great vc group in
silicon valley
i'm not that often as invoked
emotionally when i
when i read even three three short
snippets about what a company does
and i know that it also has a personal
story with you what what is
what is net quarter so med quarter
is a free application for apple and for
android that helps patients record
transcribe
and discuss medical encounters with
family members
so this was built after um my my dad got
prostate cancer
and he was on the opposite coast for me
a couple thousand miles away
and we wanted to work together to figure
out what was going on what our options
were etc
so he would get permission from his
oncologist to record the audio
of the consults he'd email that as an
attachment to me i'd listen through the
whole thing
i'd write up a summary i'd link out any
medical terms
or drugs i wasn't familiar with and i'd
email the family the workflow worked
great for getting us all on the same
page about what was going on
um but it was it was a lot of work on my
part and became clear that
most patients and their families didn't
have a workflow like this
so i started looking into recordings i
found more than 40 years of clinical
research showing
that it's a great idea to send a patient
home with a recording of the consult
they'll listen to it their family will
listen to it they'll have a much greater
understanding
of what the doctor said they'll be able
to retain a lot more and without it
critically patients
forget 90 of what they're told by the
next morning
which means that the actual consult the
time face-to-face with the doctor is
mostly wasted because you're saying
things
that the patient isn't able to retain so
i got really passionate about
patients should have recording we did
this nationwide survey we found that
almost 70 percent of americans really
wish they could have had
an audio recording of their last consult
with a doctor four percent
actually walk away from that consult
with a recording today
so it's like it's surprisingly high i
have to say i'm surprised
but that includes begins who are
recording by the way right
so so it's one of these things where
it's not super niche it turns out most
patients
uh want to better understand their
doctors and medically will do
better if they actually understand their
doctor's recordings are a proven way of
doing this
sharing those recordings with families a
proven way of doing this
and and it's not yet endemic it's not
yet something that is just part of the
standard of practice and medical care
so um so i i started designing medcor
just to make it really easy for
for families to go and do this while he
was still working at google i released
an early engineering prototype
and a few weeks after it hit the app
store my aunt terry got diagnosed with
multiple myeloma
and started using the app even in its
very early crashy state
uh to coordinate her medical care and
found it transformative and so i was
like oh man
if if my aunt is finding this super
helpful for her care
in in its current state i i need to take
this seriously so i quit my job at
google went full time on med quarter
uh founded a team raised a seed round
from future ventures
uh and and built a first class uh
native app for both uh ios and for
android as well as a web interface and
so we've got about
uh 20 000 patients and family members
across the united states we're us only
right now
um that are using the app we've got a
partnership with ucsf's patient support
core and we actually have our first
clinical trial that we kicked off
two months ago called m encore to
validate the use of med quarter with
prostate cancer patients so the results
of that should be out in q2 of next year
where we'll be able to prove that giving
patients med quarter
is is a really good idea um for a
complex care condition
so i i'm really passionate about the
radical proposition that patients should
understand their doctors
and med quarter is the vehicle for that
mission
david so when you mention that when you
start off you're still you're just
writing prototypes you're on was using
the prototype
were you writing the actual prototype no
i was
uh i i'll be honest i contracted out
with
a dev shop full stack dev shop to go and
do it uh
we wrote the front end in flutter and
did the back end in firebase
um and uh i was just providing product
direction
right so yeah yeah yeah i mainly love
the idea that it's
you don't you know you obviously have
all the capabilities you need in order
to build
these things yourself but you're
leveraging your passion and intuition
to help get these ideas across even
using other skills i mean and we have
you know the it's it it's a worldwide
economy right now and every
we have people all over the world that
can do it you're both supporting them
you're getting this idea across and now
you validated it you're going to help
and you know potentially millions of
people is
it and it's almost as if their life
depends on it right i mean literally
oh cool cool yeah the full stack
developer who we ended up finding
through that firm who's been full time
on med quarter and the like for
uh two and a half years now we actually
just this last month brought on board to
our team
as uh he's based in minsk
in belarus so yeah wow yeah yeah
that's just wonderful david 20 minutes
go by
way too quickly i i really want to thank
you for the inspiration both now and for
the time you gave seven years ago at
hacking generation y
i i just love talking to you i love your
energy and
and i i resonate so well with with your
teacher and your optimization for
learning i
i'm i'm a curious passionate person
myself
and and this is i i'm very direct and
honest this is like a role model for me
right now just listening to this and
and seeing your journey a really
wonderful before we end i have to ask
for three words that you would use to
describe yourself
or that any anybody who knows you will
describe you
i start things i start things
david thank you so much just just
phenomenal
thank you very very much stay safe and
stay healthy take care